i knew i
was wrong but i hope and i pray
you'll forgive me when i've
[Music]
forgive me and remember
what i've sang in my last hillbilly song
when i sang my typical song
when i've
[Music]
what do i call you wild man i asked for
what they called me
wild man or cliff right clifford
yeah where'd you grow up where are you
from originally i'm from wyoming county
west virginia well
i spent what 28 years down there
it's uh closer to virginia i'm well
not probably i'll say it's pretty close
but not that close okay and tell me
about your family growing up you had mom
and dad
my mom and dad
we all growed up when depression was in
and they made
i mean they made man's meat when you
could get
and nah
that was perfect never had no better
parents
that's great to hear and
but after
well they passed away it's of hard
to talk about that
but you had a good childhood ah yeah
let me mention that
how far do you in i school eighth grade
man
that's firstly up because
after that i mean if you could play
basketball
they shift you to like i don't know
what you want to talk like a skateboard
or something
if you want to put it that way
but yeah
you went you went to you went to work at
that age right now i went to work with a
14 year old what kind of work did your
father do
my father he was a coal miner for
36 years
but me now i worked
i could ride aways and everything for
like 36 years
and then i finally restarted man
i figured it's time to give everything
up
and i don't know i guess
down the road i probably wish i hadn't
done but
i did
and i probably need to get back into it
but
not
so what kind of work have you done in
your life now my life
i've done about pretty much everything i
managed to
imagine i've done
carton to work i've done
construction work
pretty well everything
got my name nothing i can't do it
natural holiday i'm 70 year old
70. and uh you've had kids
you've raised kids oh i've got
five beautiful kids
and i hope they get to see this
that i really do
i've got one south carolina or two in
south carolina
and one in north carolina
so you live up here you live up here on
the top of this hill
oh yeah man you ain't never
this weather up here
let me tell you this weather changes in
a heartbeat you could be a getting snow
one minute
no sunny next night
you do not drop your garden that is one
thing you don't do up here
i'm telling you this because it's true
you do not drop your guard for
anything if you do
not you might be snowy
and this is one but this is a little
alaska up here
everywhere
you've got 11 acres up here yeah 11
acres you're living by yourself up here
on this hilltop
yeah and i live over me live up man
your electricity i'm because you have a
generator for electricity yep
you're running water no no i hauled my
water
that was my next thing i'm getting ready
to take you
now i all the ones
because why get the one
that's purified anyway but
nah not unless you live up here
you ain't gonna know what life is
until you do live up here
it's a very different lifestyle than the
most of these things lord have mercy
man you ain't never seen a lifestyle
until you do that you hunt for your own
food
well now that
i take what i need when i need
but i don't take a lot
what kind of animals you have up here i
got deer
bear
cones pretty much anything you want
but nah i don't take nothing
that only that's a fact
you get lonely up here
i am once in a while but five
kind of go out the road and take care of
things so
yeah why are you getting personal you
have friends in town
oh yeah yeah tell me about we're living
in
appalachia what's what's the what are
the upsides and downsides of that
appalachian how shall i
put this
it's beautiful
but it can be deadly
or he can be nice
but you can also get lost real easy
it's a struggle up here right oh it's
worse than that
you gotta be
how do i wanna put this
menthol to survive
that's what you're gonna do
and if you survive you definitely gotta
be mental
to survive
and you ain't gonna find no better
life that's a fact
it makes a person tough doesn't it no
you have no idea how it makes a person
test
you've got to be gentle too
you know what i'm saying but you've got
to be gentle
to get where you're at
if you ain't not you ain't got no
friends
you ain't got nothing you have to have
gentle life
to be like it
have you traveled have you been around
the country
i've been more state probably almost
estates
and i believe in bellevue state
and i've been some of them
i made i ain't found one yet
that is bad
but
now some of them
well yeah i don't think i'm gonna go
there
it's not that good
towards people from other states
that i don't want to do yeah but i've
heard i've talked to many people from
kentucky and west virginia
and tennessee and they say they wouldn't
trade this for anything
well tennessee that's the volunteer
state
nah one of the beautiful states you've
ever been in
no complaint
tennessee is
actually tennessee is more or less my
home state
but not he's never beat my
back here nah now i'm a mountain man
i'll be a man
you were married before oh some
i wish you hadn't asked me that question
what was that hell i've been married
four times
now i still married i love my wife
i just hope she'd
sit my way
do you have any regrets the regret is
that i wish she'd stayed with me
but
that didn't work out that way so
you know that's life man
nothing but life it's like the water
in the wind
what was the best time of your life
when i was married that was the best
time of my life
was that when i was married back in
let's see what was it 90 2005.
i made a mistake
i still stayed with her
a lot of people would say would describe
you as as poor but you would probably
describe yourself as rich wouldn't you
oh i am
one of the richest people in the world
i mean people if god understands
that you gotta go from
one point to the next
to get to being gentle to people if you
can't do that
then you ain't people
you're saying kind like kindness is what
you're kind of saying you better believe
it
kindness
and ask what you got to do man
to get through this world you better be
kind of people
because you ain't you ain't getting
nowhere
does that make sense
that is what it's all about man kindness
all right clifford thank you so much for
uh talking with me
i love it every minute of that i wish
you and your dogs
the best of luck up here on this
mountain now trust me
we'll be here wow good
thank you very much